hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trendsenses.com
so as usual guys i want to go with you
through amc's price action
what happened yesterday guys was full of
tricks
so this market is very tough there is
definitely you know
some unexpected things that happen on
this market i mean that happen
more on this market than on the rest of
the market
let's see this together let's try to
analyze what happened and see
what this means for the next moves let's
get into it
[Music]
all right yes so let me remind you what
i was saying
yesterday first so i was bullish once
again let me quickly
here remind you the reason here breakout
guys this
whole area all right let me get rid of
those small things
okay the breakout on the 20th of july
since then guys i am bullish and i will
remain bullish even if we go back to 35
even if we go back to 31 i will remain
bullish if we break 31 things
change all right because then this
reversal is not a reversal anymore it's
still
the same move down that so we need to
find another breakout area
you know this is possible but very
unlikely to me so i am bullish here i'm
not sure
if the market is going to bounce back
you know tomorrow or if it's going to be
on friday or next monday
it's very hard to say what i can tell
you is that we have some tricks so this
one was expected i told you guys
that after the breakout usually it's
retested and
we have some buying power coming here
but
as you can see guys as i showed you many
times already
you can see that this same phenomenon
happened
here in may just after this breakout we
had
here this pool bag very deep that went
below the trend line
breakout area so here i was expecting
maybe the same thing would happen but it
happens again guys all right
again you know this yesterday's deep was
for me you know very very hard to trade
i mean here definitely if i was day
trading amc i would have been stopped
all right i'm telling you guys
because this is just very hard very hard
to trade
so right now what i think might happen
so those two weaknesses
to me they are of course not very good
but the strong buyback that happened
here
is on the other hand very good so
basically on the short term i am kind of
you know neutral it can go
you know maybe sideways a little bit
longer i have no clue guys i have no
clue but on the medium term guys i'm
bullish i'm very bullish i think we're
going to go to the 50 area within next
week
you know we need a catalyzer so we have
the shareholder meeting today guys so
this will be very interesting to follow
let's see what is happening you know
maybe some very interesting things would
be said i don't know
but definitely this is the kind of event
that can impact
the price action positively or
negatively but i hope positively
so let's see guys let's see uh once
again even if we go back to 35
it doesn't change anything for me here
there would be a real question all right
and
usually guys for those who are doing
technical analysis for a while
maybe you have noticed that when you
have this kind of you know intersect so
basically the 50
is coming from here right is the high
that i have in the
recent downtrend and it's also coming
from here
this downtrend all right the yellow one
okay and that i get connecting the highs
here
and usually those intersect there are
levels
through which the market likes to go so
you know
let's see but why not on the third of
august
trading at 50 this would make sense for
me but once again we need something
strong
we need something strong here and yeah i
i i don't know
i don't know when it's going to come but
i'm very confident this is
coming soon then i wanted to show you
quickly guys the
nice breakouts that we're having here on
fubu tv
so this is a stock i'm following closely
guys i like the stock
by the way i was telling you on my
discord every day for like three or four
days careful we are testing it we're
testing it and now we broke it so
what i would do in the situation i would
buy already a bit you know
let's say i would buy a third of my
position and then i would you know
just buy more on the on the pool bike if
your pullback
occurs around the 26 area i would buy
more i would just be a buyer and 26
26.50
and i would stop loss below 20 24. this
is the kind of trend i will set up guys
i
am now having a team so there are three
trailers
we're gonna start on the first of
september guys on this code so come now
it's still for free and you're gonna
have 50 discount for those who are
already there
so the link is in the description guys
so just click on it
access the free zone and then i'm gonna
you know just send you everything you
need
to get the memberships with 50 discount
and in the
higher membership i will give you guys
access to all of our trades
so we're gonna manage different
portfolios of around ten thousand us
dollars
and we're gonna give you all the trades
we do explain why they're gonna be
different books option book technical
analysis aggressive book where we're
gonna try to make quick money so let's
see how it goes
the technical analysis conservative book
where we're gonna try to make more
secure trades
and the macro book which is gonna be
based on fundamental analysis
so let's see which book performs the
best i think it's going to be very
interesting for you to
to follow over interesting for me and
for you know my team of traders
to do as well so i'm very very excited
about this product guys so
join now you're going to learn a lot i'm
going to do my best you know to just
transmit everything that we
coming from the bank industry and the
hedge fund industry we
know and we're gonna try to just show
you guys how
we used to work you know when we were
employees so
football tv is one of the trends i would
go in but for now this portfolio has not
started yet
blackberry guys same thing i'm telling
you about blackberry
for some time we are the bear trend here
for the past two months
and here we have the breakout guys so we
have it all right
so it's done so it doesn't mean we're
going to go higher right away you know
this is the scenario i had
last you know a few days ago so i was
just right a bit late i would say so
here maybe you expect to pull back same
thing as football tv yes
here i would be a buyer maybe uh you
know a quarter or a third of my position
and i would do
i would enter the fibs and the breakouts
so around 10 50
10 20. all this area is a good area to
buy stop loss below 940 all right so
it's a
very nice risk we will trade this is the
kind of trade i would put in my book
that would start again in september guys
so
it's gonna be very very cool to do end
game stop guys i'm sorry
i'm not bullish here for now uh not on
the short term
we are having this support that has been
broken re-tested we went
you know higher then came back hovering
against
around this level it's just not looking
good to me so
i think that the scenario where we go to
you know to take back some
more liquidity around 145 level
is playing out i can't say more here
guys i need to see more price action you
know
i would definitely not stay in this
trade if i was in
i would wait to see more bullish signals
coming so one of them
would be for example if we trade above
200 this downward sloping trend line is
to me the level to watch
so if we go above that bam bam bam
then it's looking very nice all right so
this is what we want to see
in all this area i guess everything can
happen it can move sideways it can
it can move down you know i have no clue
we are here in uh
kind of no man's land i don't know i
don't know but if we go above 200
i'm gonna be very bullish here so let's
find out guys let's find out i'm here
just giving my view
of course uh i'm trying to explain as
good as i can
you know what i'm using what i'm seeing
the reasons behind each of my
view and i hope this is helpful i hope
you guys enjoyed this video and if you
did please
don't forget guys to click on the sub
like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore see you guys